let's talk about hisoka's new Nan
abilities bungee gum has evolved texture
surprise has also evolved and hisoka may
very well now be one of the most broken
nen users in the entire Series this is
because the very existence that is
hisoka is completely unprecedented he is
currently the only person in the series
to have both cast a post-mortem nankus
and be capable of wielding that power
for himself the way nen works is all
about balance high cost equals high
output the harder it is to make the more
of a punch it's going to pack straight
into the proverbial nut sack of your
enemies and that's why post mortem net
is the ultimate expression of Aura
because its cost is the condition that
the user dies and not only that but just
before death they need to be
experiencing an emotion so profound that
it invokes the user's Aura to linger
long after the Solas left the world for
example nefepito's desire to protect
marowam resulted in a super powered
turps Cora being left behind as Peter
passed on the meteor City Elder also
felt such a strong desire to protect his
people that his sun and moon ability
remained in crawler's skill Hunter after
his death and speaking of the troop they
were so incredibly afraid to kill
karapika after the events of York New
City out of fear that his curse on
crawler would only become that much more
powerful due to karapikas admittedly
rather intense desire for vengeance at
the time the interesting thing is that
all of these cases are desires to do
with someone else or a group of someone
else's either to protect the someone
else's or to do the opposite very much
not protect them kill them even but
hisoka is our first exciting example of
a very selfish use of post-mortem
following a very deathsome encounter
with hisoka's primary love interest
crawler our excitable battle clown lost
his life but not before invoking bungee
gum to restart his heart and thus
resurrect hisoka hisoka's desire to live
was so strong that his nun just went
yeah sure why not I'll do that for you
buddy the first person we know of to
both cast and wield post-mortem Nan it's
a terrifying Prospect because hisoka
found a very tricksy loophole here now
capable of using powers that cost his
death but without needing to experience
the true finality of that cost as a
result he's demonstrated a slew of new
abilities including including being able
to replicate his own body parts with
bungee gum potentially capable of
healing or replacing his own internal
organs as well and text your surprise
can perfectly mimic his skin so that
he's not just walking around the hunt
hunt world looking like a glob of jelly
that wasn't left in the fridge quite
long enough or Jello for our American
viewers and as I understand it Jello is
always jelly but jelly is not always
Jello because you can make jelly from
things that aren't Jello but that's a
video for another time because we need
to look at the implications of hisoka's
post-mortem State not just in terms of
his evolved existing abilities but also
in regards to where he sits on the nen
ring hisoka is a pure transmuter meaning
that this is certainly the area that
receives the highest boost however his
neighboring affinities of enhancement
and conjuration are also going to be
much more accessible than ever before
which could lead to an absurd amount of
modification potential also this video
is sponsored by raycon the wireless
earbuds offering earsomely premium sound
a completely comfortable fit and a
whopping 54 hours of battery life I use
earbuds a lot like a lot A lot cleaning
dog walking video editing gaming not
gaming everything so comfortable and
long lasting earbuds are Paramount and
this this is Comfort they make perfect
gifts for all of the people mother
father co-worker Fitness friend gamer
Everyone likes to hear things I assure
you in fact you can knock the whole list
off at once and get 30 off by shopping
raycon's holiday bundles such as the
audio lover bundle providing both the
everyday earbuds and everyday headphones
for maximum audio coverage and as the
person gifting them you will be thrilled
to know that they start at half the
price of other premium Brands click the
link in the description or go to buy
recon.com new world and use code early
BF to get 20 off site wide or save even
bigger and get 30 off raycon's exclusive
holiday bundles there will also be
different deals coming out throughout
the season and I'll try to keep the
description updated with the latest
offers but just so you know you can
always go to buy recon.com new world to
get the best deals available for acon so
do that thing but pronounce back to you
me starting with the basics enhancement
which is usually the boring guy punch
things hard ability but not in this case
one of hisoka's balance weaknesses is a
bungee gum can only stretch about 10
meters before it tears however with
enhanced enhancement hisoka could
potentially stretch his bungee gum even
further which is already a devastating
outcome in and of itself hisoka is such
an incredibly intelligent tactician that
increasing his options in fight battling
is never a great outcome plus it would
effectively expand his field of attack
as well there's also the potential for
gum hardening right now hisoker is happy
with his sloppy sticky rubber goop but
this does often cause him problems
because bungee gum in and of itself
can't actually harm opponents that's why
during the fight against crolo he had to
improvise by using a severed head as a
mace very clever very balanced but also
a bit convoluted whereas if he could say
hard in a glob of gum then he could
create some very cool options well not
necessarily just like a random globby
ball thing but even shape the gum into
some kind of cool objects like Hammers
and spikes in your other deadly things
quite similar to an ability we've
recently seen in the manga with the
Haley Mafia family member turning his
arm into a variety of death and juicing
tools which he did as a conjurer very
inefficiently by the way but hisoka is
in the perfect position to execute
something like this if he so desired
transmuters and conjurers seem to be
much more capable of morphing their own
bodies efficiently such as bisky and
tsubani but the thing is hisoka would be
able to do this even easier because he
doesn't have to turn his actual body
into a vehicle or a weapon or in
anything because what he's using as his
body right now is transmuted Aura but
since hisoka can already replicate parts
of his body with bungee gum why not go
one step further and morph his body into
gum like a logia style devil fruit from
wacky pirate comic one piece body
morphing in Hunter Hunter is rare but
again not unheard of especially not in
hisoka's neighborhood of the nen ring
sabane did it with Rider's high so the
principle here would be that instead of
conjuring your body into an object
you're transmuting it into a substance
which usually would not at all be
recommended for example if kilowa were
to transmute his body into electricity
then he would risk losing whatever body
part became a substance because it would
dissipate and probably leave him with no
limbs however bungee gum is a very
different substance it doesn't dissipate
like electricity smoke or fire it
lingers or I should say it sticks so
there's much less risk associated with
hisoka transmuting his own body if that
is indeed possible I should say that
there's also a much more morbid solution
to this as well for getting transmuting
the body there is a world where hisoka
could simply Lop off his various body
parts one by one and replace them with
bungee gum Prosthetics layer dinner
Delight some texture surprise because I
I suppose that's the thing if hisoka
does fight a powerful opponent and loses
another arm or a leg or whatever then
that's going to be the solution anyway
so why not preempt it it would also make
hisoka infinitely more durable in battle
there is no doubt that bungee gum is far
stronger than the human body skin and
bones are fragile very very fragile
that's why the first thing you learn
about nen is how not to break yourself
but a body with the properties of both
Rubber and gum well that's infinitely
more durable even if an opponent was to
cut off a limb hisoka would just regrow
it and usually I would say there would
be an extremely high cost associated
with doing such a thing but post-mortem
Nan has made hisoka the equivalent of a
nen billionaire he can afford to pay
insane costs even if it's objectively
inefficient because he more or less
exists outside of the system even with
that I'd say there would still be need
for some restriction like kisoka
probably can't just turn his whole body
into gum at the very least he'd need
some sort of core remaining like a brain
and or heart a weak and beatable core if
you're not careful with it knowing
hisoka he may even elect keep his raging
Schwing maker as well and hey there's
also a good argument to be made that
that's exactly where he soak his brain
is anyway but as mad as this sounds
remember we are talking about hisoka
here and I could absolutely see him
removing his own Limbs and replacing
them with gun Prosthetics because the
fun battling to be had and it's also a
bizarrely appropriate use of post-mortem
Nan like gradually saying goodbye to
your previously living body and all of
that looking at the other side of the
nen ring though we also shouldn't ignore
the potential for omission and
manipulation the latter of which is
hisoka's exact opposite affinity and
generally we would dismiss it entirely
as I imagine hisoka did during his first
life simply because because it's a very
inefficient way to spend ore again
though hisoker is now Mr Moneybags when
it comes to Aura and he can spend it on
all sorts of net equivalents of private
jets and golden toilets which in this
case would be manipulation he could
Pioneer a combination of transmutation
and manipulation by transmuting gum Aura
into a rather hisoka-shaped clone and
then use manipulation to command it
which there is precedent for because
that's exactly how moral controls his
smoke clones he transmutes the aura into
smoke and then he goes and controls them
except he has to go through the
Restriction of the pipe and also
incorporate a mission to make it work
due to the fact that he is a
post-mortemless pleb with this hisoka
could even pull a crawler on crowler
during their fight crolo constantly got
the better of hisoka by having other
people forcibly impersonate him so if
there was a rematch then having crolo
face he Soca clones would make this
whole conflict come full circle emphasis
on the word come another example of
successful cloning with unsuccessful
affinities is of course Castro the
enhancer who used conjuration and
manipulation however the aura investment
was the equivalent of dumping all of
your money into Dogecoin whereas hisoka
has traditionally been a rather astute
investor but with that said he now has
so much more Aura capital and so many
more Market opportunities it's at the
point where it almost doesn't matter
where he sits on an end ring the only
thing that gives us is which part of the
duel or even Trio of affinities that he
could Implement hisoka is unprecedented
and unrestricted right now the only
thing that is pretty much off the table
is specialization but even then you know
things could happen but something we
absolutely must not forget is texture
surprise this discussion so far it's all
been very gum-centric but the most
exciting potential ability for me comes
from texture surprise texture surprise
involves the soccer Conjuring typically
paper and changing both the visual and
physical properties to replicate a
texture which I take the time to point
out because it's common misconception
that hisoka just like carry sheets of
paper around with him for emergency use
but they are definitely conjured you
know come to think of it his playing
cards are probably conjured as well
which is why they're far more deadly
than regular playing cards that and he's
like coating them in a layer of shoe and
all that like nen is complicated and
compounding it's a lot of things in any
case hisoka generally conjures these
small sheets of paper but texture
surprise would work with anything smooth
and flat I guess the paper is just the
cheapest and most effective cost Aura
wise and according to hisoka texture
surprise is able to replicate over 1 000
textures pre-death it was very
underutilized which I suppose only helps
with keeping the surprise element intact
and with that in mind the one thing that
hisoka learned from his fight with
crawler was to never let his opponent
choose the battlefield in fact in
chapter 357 he States gee fighting
someone of krolllo's caliber it's
difficult under the opponent's ideal
conditions well reality is Harsh so my
proposal would be what if hisoka had a
way of controlling the battlefield
luring his opponents in to fight under
his ideal conditions an example of which
would be using texture surprise to
create a space perfectly suited to
hisoka or using texture surprise to lure
his opponents into a space they feel is
more ideal for them before revealing
that they are in fact somewhere that's
that's not there an example of this may
be no banaga he absolutely excels in
small spaces so hisoka might be able to
use an enhanced texture surprise to
mimic a small room only to reveal that
they're in a much larger and more
gum-friendly environment it's sort of
like a jack-in-the-box except your jack
and there's no box only a surprise
murder clown because it's promiscuous of
a combatant as he is I don't think that
hisoka is going to just step into a late
night taxi with anyone anymore hisoka
has much more refined tastes he's not
interested in crolo's venue of a holiday
and he'd much rather fight in his
five-star Hilton venue or whatever he
wanted to because with text a surprise
he could make just about anything work
basically he just needs to conjure like
much larger sheets of paper which is
probably quite an or intensive thing to
do even though it's just paper but
without rage's Aura quantities that cost
just isn't really a problem anymore so I
think there's definitely something to be
said for the potential of environmental
manipulation and even though the
illumias he soak her idea is well and
truly debunked using a combination of
Bungee gum and texture surprise to
change hisoka's appearance is certainly
not off the table bungee gum to morph
the body into the appropriate
proportions and text your surprise to
provide realistic texture capable of
surprise which would again mimic an
ability that crawler used against hisoka
in the heavens Arena fight hisoka's
potential is Limitless right now his Nan
is in Uncharted Territory he may very
well be the most powerful nen user
currently aboard the Blackwell one and
with the death of both ant king maroum
and Isaac nataro perhaps even the most
powerful in the entire human Realm